[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france 24 ya está comido en el estudio
rosa pérez masdéu rosa bienvenida buena
mañana de martes vamos a abrir entonces
esta revista de prensa con un tema en
específico vamos a comentar las
novedades sobre el controvertido informe
que publicó la organización amnistía
internacional el pasado 4 de agosto en
esta explicaba las prácticas militares
que ucrania ponía en riesgo la vida de
los civiles lo comentamos porque rosa
ahora oksana a paul a chuck la ex
directora de la organización en ucrania
argumenta que en washington post' porque
renunció tras la publicación de este
reporte rosa exactamente buenos días
raúl este artículo de opinión de oksana
vocal chuck se publicó este fin de
semana como bien decías en este
periódico estadounidense y la que fue
directora ejecutiva de amnistía
internacional en ucrania entre 2016 y el
5 de agosto de este año 2022 es decir un
día después de la publicación de este
informe explica argumenta porque
renunció a su trabajo en la organización
en una párrafo inicial resumen bastante
bien digamos su posicionamiento lo leo a
continuación a textualmente dice el 4 de
agosto amnistía internacional publicó un
informe que acusaba al ejército
ucraniano de violar las leyes de la
guerra al ubicar bases militares cerca
de infraestructura civil el reporte
desató una oleada de críticas alrededor
del mundo y en ucrania para mí el mayor
error del informe fue como contra dijo
su principal objetivo lejos de proteger
a los civiles los puso todavía más en
peligro al dar a rusia una justificación
para continuar con sus ataques
indiscriminados por eso renuncie como
jefa de la oficina de ucrania de
amnistía internacional muchos de mis
colegas me siguieron ella asegura que
hasta el momento es decir desde 2016
cuando asumió el cargo estaba orgullosa
de su trabajo y del trabajo de amnistía
internacional sin embargo insiste en que
el enfoque actual de la organización al
respecto a lo que sucede en ucrania es
contradictoria con a su misión
y digamos a qué atribuye esa situación y
la publicación del informe bien a un
tema muy particular ella dice que la
mayoría de investigaciones e informes
que se llevan a cabo a ucrania para
investigar los crímenes de guerra y un
poco pues la evolución del conflicto
estas investigaciones dicen las llevan a
cabo un especial equipo de crisis dice
que este equipo está especializado en
conflicto armado alrededor del mundo y
que tiene una profunda formación en el
derecho internacional humanitario en
derechos humanos en armamento etcétera
sin embargo insiste la que fuera
directora ejecutiva de amnistía
internacional ucrania que este equipo
carece de conocimientos sobre el
contexto y las lenguas los idiomas
locales no y sin embargo esto digamos
que se contradice un poco con el informe
en sí que más adelante digamos
analizaremos también el informe que
publicó amnistía internacional el 4 de
agosto y que hizo renunciar a esta ex
directora ejecutiva sin en porque
digamos ahí en ese informe se citan
directamente bastantes testigos civiles
sin embargo volvemos oksana poca luz lo
que dice es que este equipo especial de
crisis no trabajó adecuadamente con los
equipos locales ucranianos sin embargo
no acaba de definir a qué se refiere
cuando dice adecuadamente no sabemos
cuál fue exactamente la cooperación
entre los equipos de amnistía
internacional
ucrania y este equipo especial de crisis
para allá digamos rosso cuáles son los
errores de este informe bien este
informe señala como comentábamos no que
el ejército ucraniano pone en peligro a
los civiles al ubicar bases militares
pues en las zonas residenciales ella lo
que dice es que esto no está
específicamente prohibido por el derecho
internacional
humanitario sin embargo sí que reconoce
que hay que evitarlo en la medida de lo
posible pero que hay que analizarlo caso
por caso y que dado la realidad sobre el
terreno en ucrania y que rusia lo que
busca es ocupar ciudades y tras las
atrocidades que se han visto por ejemplo
en mucha dice no está claro que al
retirarse de áreas pobladas el ejército
ucraniano proteja a los civiles ese es
principalmente su argumento por otro
lado también reprocha a la organización
que no haya dado suficiente tiempo de
respuesta a kiev al gobierno ucraniano
porque supuestamente amnistía
internacional mandó digamos una
notificación sobre que iba a publicar
este informe al ministerio de defensa de
que había al gobierno básicamente
ucraniano el 29 de julio y no obtuvo
respuesta hasta el 4 de agosto cuando
publicó este este informe las
principales conclusiones de su informe
rosa viena zona 3 ahora sí que vamos a
lole señala amnistía internacional por
un lado que las bases militares como
decíamos establecidas en áreas
residenciales incluidas escuelas y
hospitales y los ataques lanzados desde
zonas civiles convierte a los civiles en
objetivos militares lo que vulneraría el
derecho internacional humanitario y por
otro lado insiste en que tales
violaciones no justifican los ataques
indiscriminados de rusia que han matado
y herido a incontables civiles
simplemente entre algunas de las
conclusiones que señala
artículo pues dice que este informe
perdón que 19 ciudades desde 19 ciudades
se lanzaron ataques no desde edificios a
civiles y particularmente que en cinco
lugares se usaron hospitales como bases
militares sin embargo no se especifica
en qué ciudades pero también este
informe dice que rusia usa armamento
ilegal como bombas de racimo la propia
mis internacional rosa publicó un
comentario respecto exactamente para
terminar amnistía internacional cuatro
días después de la publicación del
informe el 8 de agosto en una reporte en
una nota de prensa dijo que lamentaba
profundamente el dolor y el enojo
causado por ese comunicado no porque es
de lenski entre otras personas dijo que
estaban acusando a la víctima digamos de
la situación pero dice a pesar que
lamentamos este dolor y este un ojo
mantenemos nuestras conclusiones y dicen
no responsabilizamos a ucrania de las
violaciones de derechos humanos
cometidos por rusia pero digamos raúl
este es sin duda el centro del debate
que cada uno pues tendrá distintas
opiniones rosa muchísimas gracias como
siempre por toda la información pasamos
a saludar a nuestro primer invitado el
día